let's jump to the story and uh make
everybody angry you may have seen the
story but we're gonna we're gonna bring
it up here for this Friday show this is
from today.com she offered a lgbtq minus
themed book to her children normally
they put the plus but there's like a
dash there so I had to say minus anyway
they say she offered an lgbtq themed
book to her middle schoolers parents
filed a police report
Danielle Campo amore she writes the
story saying she'd been at Illinois's
Middle School teacher for 20 years so
Middle School is uh what is that eight
to twelve eight to thirteen uh middle
schools eight to twelve yeah the book in
question is a book called this book is
gay
the article from today doesn't tell you
what she actually did I am going to keep
the language family friendly for all of
you because you may have children
listening
this teacher provided instruction to
children
children ages presumably middle
schoolers so we're 8 to 13 on how to
meet adult men for gay sex
she provided them on instruction on how
to consume
the bodily materials of other adult men
yeah there's that language again they
win this is the language because
I think I told him exactly what it was
I'm being academic no I'm saying this is
why the article wins because the average
person reads it doesn't know that that's
what it says
it's an lgbtq themed book exactly it's
like that Meme says like no matter how
much you hate journalists you don't hate
them enough like this this is the the
that's well hold on that's what they
were saying about the other I have a
question I have a question Danielle
capua Moore wrote this
why did she not include that this
teacher was providing this degree of
instruction to children
because they're trying to hide it from
parents but but why would you want to
hide it from parents why does Danielle
Campo Amore this writer for today
not want parents to know that this
teacher
was instructing their children
on how to arrange Anonymous adult
activity activities with adults sexual
activities why why is she trying to
obfuscate this I think because you know
depravity and perversion seeks more of
that more of the same thing right you're
getting warmer but what does that what
does that mean you're saying that
Danielle Campo more is depraved and
perverted I mean clearly yeah to lead to
leave out is it possible then that maybe
Danielle campomore shares certain
predilections for children that this
teacher might
is she also gay well I don't know about
that that that's not Material I mean
that's how she would write it I suppose
right but we're talking about a
middle-aged teacher giving a book to
children that explains them how to eat
male fluids or I shouldn't say I'll be
very careful provides instruction on the
process of because it does I want to be
I'm being fair it does tell them not to
do it yes it says it says it's not safe
but it does include
definitional breakdown of
how it occurs and also what it means to
consume feces
these things are being provided to
children but more importantly it
explains to them in detail how to use
applications to upload their images as
children this is illegal it's
instructing them on
making
images of themselves to share with
adults for anonymous encounters
I can only assume I think it's the only
fair assessment is possibly why someone
working for a media organization would
obfuscate this they too are attracted to
children
because I anybody who any any sane adult
who doesn't want children being harmed
this way is not going to cover up for
another pedophile or if they're
ideologically possessed they would yeah
I mean I I don't I mean I don't know
you're saying that perhaps Danielle
Campo more is not a pedophile herself
but that she wants to protect pedophiles
yes 100 I am absolutely saying that with
a full-throated I am saying that
actually I I would agree with that
because maybe it's it's viewed as like
you had that big movement I can say big
movement you had that that movement
among pedophiles lgbtp where they're
trying to get their get the P added to
their absolutely it didn't work but it
would make sense with that Ted Talk
where that woman tried saying it's like
she tried claiming it was normal you
have journalists who are like yes I
agree with you I will protect you people
that are familiar with queer Theory uh I
think Gail Rubin is one of the original
idea for queer Theory uh Mario malali
was a uh an Italian guy that was writing
in queer Theory
Foucault who's a post-modern leftist all
of these people that dip into queer
Theory have all in some way defended
pedophilia the uh Gail Rubin calls it um
called the intergenerational and these
are all things that if you want to go
and read the text in queer Theory this
is The Cutting Edge in sociology
departments I just got into an argument
today with a friend of mine not argument
but we were going back and forth on
Twitter and he's like this you know this
stuff isn't happening blah blah and I'm
like go look because I am not the one
that's asserting these things all I'm
doing is relaying the information that
are in books in sociology departments in
queer theory in LGBT studies in probably
in women's studies these are the ideas
that are in the sociology departments I
don't like them I don't want them to be
there I didn't put them there but don't
get mad at me because I know they're
there
when they say that it's not being taught
that nobody's talking about it that it's
not real there was an episode of the
good doctor in 2018 where they talk
about a person who has a desire for
interactions with children and they and
they in the episode they treat it with
empathy because he has not acted on it
and that's just to say 2018 we're
talking a very long time ago in that
when you really think about how long
that's been mainstream so it's not new
in any way shape no and they've tried to
change the language on this too right
they're calling pedophiles there's a
push to call them minor attraction
persons yeah exactly so I think you know
this is this proves that the slippery
slope is in fact very slippery I think a
lot of us especially meows a little bit
more libertarian in my college days I
kind of laughed when Christian
conservative said you know pushing for
gay marriage is gonna open the
floodgates and it really has I mean look
at what we're dealing with today in just
a short amount of time
or the stories of people who get to a
guy gets to go to a woman's prison
because uh because he identifies a
different way it really is when you
allow that much subjectivity to the real
world bad things can happen I love the
uh why do you care so much
it's like Sheamus likes to bring it up
and then there was a I so what happened
with the show we're supposed to do this
morning is that I made a comment that
was very dry
statement in my opinion about
um
denormalization of transgender
individuals and it was Kim Petras on the
cover of Sports Illustrated Swimsuit now
Kim is biologically male has undergone
many surgeries and the the image had Kim
halfway underwater so you could only see
half of the chest and up
and
in response to my Tweet someone said
something like
if if it wasn't for grifters like Tim
you wouldn't even know that these people
existed and my response was except for
when they're on the cover of Sports
Illustrated magazine and had like won a
Grammy this year and and right was
singing with um uh Sam Smith no I'm like
I would love to talk about the Middle
East right now did you guys see Assad he
met with Saudi Arabia hey how about this
Saudi this year the Civil War is
basically over Assad one and him teaming
up with having this meeting implies the
Petro dolls on the way out how about we
talk about things like that instead no
but our culture was dominated by people
who are gutting it from the ground up so
I certainly want to talk about it Sports
Illustrated is actually interesting
because it is like the hierarchy of what
is acceptable in our society right now
there was four covers there was the Kim
Petras you have Tran a trans individual
you have Martha Stewart so you got an 81
year old lady then you have Megan Fox
she her whole thing was talking about
body dysmorphia and then there was just
another lady named like Brooke Nader
Brooks Nader who I wonder if she's
related to Ralph Nader because that
would be very cool if that was true but
hers was just I won a beauty contest and
I like why can't we talk about that this
lady like beat out 10 000 other people
to get this job because that doesn't
sell anymore because there is no ESG
funding in that story there is no
ideological way to Virtue signal to
people that you want to build your base
they're always looking to build this
Phantom audience the people who are
buying Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
editions don't care about Kim Petras at
least not if they're paying attention
and definitely don't care about seeing
Martha Stewart on the cover but there's
that's the hierarchy now you have to be
some type of oppressed group you have to
fit into Infinity group someplace for it
to be relevant in the culture the
culture that they're pushing on us do
people still read these things uh I mean
I was trying to explain that I was like
you will not understand how important
this was as a symbol in the 90s maybe
not So Much Anymore tablet edition of it
I have no idea like I when you go to
like a Walgreens or Walmart or something
you see the magazine section you'll
notice when you're checking out at
Walmart the magazines don't have names
anymore it's a thing so like
I see a magazine and it just said it
said Captain America all really big on
it and I'm like what magazine is this
and then really really tiny It's Time
Magazine
because it doesn't matter anymore they
know
nobody's buying their magazine what they
do know is or maybe maybe not time but
like the logo is really small people
will see oh I like Captain America I
will buy a Captain America thing and
then they're buying the magazine
because people aren't reading them
anymore no I mean and there is a certain
homogeneity of the message like you you
get GQ with you know trans men on it and
uh you know
what is it health with yeah fat ladies
on it and it's just yeah it's just the
total homogenization of the of the
message it doesn't matter if you're
picking up a rolling stone or if you're
picking up GQ or if you're picking up
you know women's health or whatever
you're getting the same message I it is
absolutely the same message I just going
back to whether or not this uh
these people can they're they're they're
the left can survive in the future I
just I just don't see it I just I I
can't see this stuff making its way into
the future because for one like I
mentioned it's self-destructive but
people are not like people so I'll put
it this way
I made the joke on Twitter based off of
John dye's joke I said start
complimenting liberal women by saying
they look like they look like Dylan Mo
venue or lizzo everybody immediately
understands what the what the what the
joke is while these liberal women will
say Dylan mulvania is beautiful or lizzo
is beautiful if you say you look just
like them they will get angry because
inside they know they're lying they
don't find these people attractive
that's the kind of thing that says to me
this cannot survive this cannot persist
the the the culture they have of lying
about how they really really feel about
things
everyone on the surface might lie but
then they won't actually act upon those
things those things will not exist yeah
they can go on and and and and on top of
that too
if you if they keep coming out and
saying people like lizzo are beautiful
like this is going to lead to a high
mortality rate for a lot of people
once again it is it is resulting in the
loss of life on the left the right is
more likely to be like cut out the sugar
stop eating seed oils how many how many
people how many times have you heard in
the past week stop eating seed oils like
come on the right won't shut up about it
that in the microplastics but see like
the right whatever that is is trying
really hard to be healthy to be
responsible I got glass bottled water
here we get it for all our guests you do
have plastic because we you know we're
not that crazy we just try to do better
but if the long the long run the
trajectory just seems very simple the
left starts to disappear and the right
expands I get what you're saying but
like historically when we've seen these
kind of ideologies try to push for
influence and stuff there's Mass debt so
you could be right there could be a lot
of people that end up dying that but
that's also something that happens Mass
death in which direction I mean well if
they get in if they get in control if
they get into positions of power and
actually can decide can make policy then
you're going to end up seeing a massive
push for for the reduction of carbon
usage and the reduction that means
reduction of energy usage they don't
want to use uh petrochemicals to to
fertilize any plants and stuff so you're
going to see famines of not just
conservative or not just left but
conservatives why conservatives because
they're well it would be a worldwide
death because you you'll see like you'll
see significant famine not that would it
can say they're not going to start with
the US it'll be in places where that
where there's already on the edge of
famine American conservatives will be
the last to go sure sure and that and
then what happens 20 years later
conservative United States I mean maybe
so we can put it this way
let's say
the there's two potential Forks the left
sterilizing and aborting their kids
they're promoting unhealthy Lifestyles
and promoting sterilization of
individuals over a long enough period of
time they just won't exist okay well let
me finish that's one potential the other
potential is they gain massive political
power of the institutions take over and
then start culling their opponents
either way the Great Famine whatever
ends up happening as we often see with
big communist regimes the Soviet Union
lasted about 69 years and then what
happens it falls apart if it does
conservatives who tend to have their own
sources of food to a to a greater degree
than liberals that the pressure is still
apparent the left taking over means
famine and death but it's the people in
the cities who are Urban liberals who
are the first to struggle and have no
access to resources conservatives aren't
about the middle of nowhere nowhere with
chickens goats guns and a garden at the
very least not every single one will
strive I'm sorry will Thrive but many of
them will be okay plus all the preppers
are right leaning I I don't disagree
with the ultimate result like I don't
think that the the the left will
ultimately win because I think that
constantly it eats itself and there's
all kinds of problems in the ideology
um it's I just don't think that it's
going to be any kind of uh smooth
sailing to get who's that it was smooth
sailing no I'm not I'm not saying it
could be the most catastrophic nightmare
scenario we could imagine but the end
result is the right wins I think likely
because I think that uh I think there's
there's Merit to your arguments about
the way that people on the right live
and the way that they organizationalize
and stuff but I'm looking at it just
like basic probabilities right you you
don't you bet not a horse race when you
bet on the long shot horse 40-1 you win
around 40 to 1. imagine if they were
like the horse that got a 40 40 to 1
chance to win and we'll give you you
know you bet 100 bucks we'll give you
ten dollars if you win you'd be like wow
I want to do that I'll like what I'm
gonna lose and even when I don't get
anything I'm looking at this right now
it's like the probability exists that
sure sure when you're looking at any
roll of the die we'll do that it's
possible that Snake Eyes comes up it
happens all the time but it's just one
in 30 rolls for it to happen so it's
unlikely I think it is very unlikely in
the long term the left succeeds they may
have short-term victories they may get
they they have many institutions I
believe right now but over a long enough
period of time it just fails because
it's not physically possible even if we
break it down to just simple economics
centralized command economies cannot
work right just unless there is some AI
takeover
yeah well I mean let's go with that
is it also fair to point out that
there's a difference between whether
we're talking leftist tactics in the
average neoliberal who will definitely
support a lot of these policies but are
raising kids that are still going to end
up in government still are having
traditional families they're just not
telling you that the things that we're
talking about are a problem right they
still support them they just don't it's
nimbyism they just don't support it in
their own backyard they're they're fine
with that like those kids yeah so the
the problem is that like yeah you could
in a lot of ways the The Fringe types
are going to find themselves eliminated
from the gene pool with their decisions
but the Nancy Pelosi's and the the rest
of the politi the politicians are still
having kids they're still expanding and
creating their own political oligarchies
in a lot of ways with their families I I
don't see if necessarily it goes away
that quickly I I think the establishment
people just do whatever they think earns
them power and if the left is removing
themselves culturally and physically
then you will Democrats will will gladly
come out they will gladly come out in
support for cutting taxes for the rich
if the power structures support that
idea it doesn't matter they they're
they're vanilla yogurt you know what I
mean just like whatever whatever's
happening in the world they'll say like
sure so
I think It ultimately comes down to we
have two big populist wave populist
waves and one is like not like everybody
on the right is healthy and fit but more
likely to be meritocratic more likely to
live in rural areas with better air with
access to at least some ability to get
their own food I mean look right right
now outside I can see all the mulberries
growing and we have those mock
strawberries it's really fun Have You
Ever Seen The Mock strawberries no I
don't even know about these things I'll
move out here there are these little
tiny yellow flowers and they grow what
looks like strawberries on them and uh
you can eat them they're just flavorless
they're like pretty bland and no one
really cares for them but the chickens
eat them they they gobble them up so I'm
like I'm out here we got chickens we had
eggs we got berries we got the Paw Paw
fruits that are like crazy and we're not
even trying to have that food you live
in a city
there's no food outside you go to a
store you get your food or you don't out
here we have choices on walking outside
and finding things to eat if we so
choose then typically go to the grocery
store but putting it at that if Society
collapsed right now
we out here in the middle of nowhere
would have little bits of food in the
city they would have none
that's enough
people out here will sir are more likely
to survive than people in cities
not to mention all the pressures that
come from population density in those
places where everything when something
bad happens I am wrong they actually
have a lot more food in the cities than
we do out here each other exactly but
for real though there's no people out
here so it's like I gotta eat a deer we
got a lot of deer though there's so many
deer out here turkeys too how's your car
there sir uh I still haven't gotten
looked at but it's it's just annoying
there's too many they're everywhere you
had a deer yeah I had a deer uh going on
the highway when it was foggy today yeah
when recently uh yes on what was it
Monday Tuesday wow something right it's
just because it's foggy and there's
there's literally so many of them
they're like I think we gotta eat them
yeah literally I know you know I'm
trying to eat the chickens but my
brother doesn't want to eat any of them
he's like no we can't come on talk about
the the guys in the back of the well the
roosters for sure I've been trying to
make roosters stew for like a year but
my brother's like we can't eat them man
like the foxes are eating them like I
think a couple of them died
but they're mostly out okay we're King
Roberto is still all right he's in
retirement he's doing he's doing well
but I'm ready we got too many we got
babies now they had they make more of
themselves and then we give them scraps
we give them leftovers they eat bugs
it's because they're not turning their
kids into trans individuals they're
actually happy that they actually you
know well actually we mostly bread out
of the chickens the broodiness
so yeah it's actually not super easy the
silkies will have babies yeah the fluffy
chickens they they just they desperately
want to have babies and then we have a
coach in and she had two babies and so
she stands there with little babies very
cute you know and then one day we'll eat
them yeah because it's food and I have
no problems I don't care I'm like yes
they're cute yes I love my chickens and
they're also my food chickens are it's
really hard to love chickens they're so
stupid that's why I love them well I
mean like a dog I get it I get loving
book because I get loving a cat chickens
they're they're tough to love they're
nah well shame is funny Sheamus spent
two hours on our podcast talking about
how dogs don't have the capacity to love
yeah he's wrong yeah he's totally wrong
uh you see here's the thing about
Roberto Jr he walks around minding his
own business and he's a stand-up guy we
had we had leftover Sushi today and we
went out the sashimi and when we would
try and give some to him he would make
sure the girls got it instead he he
never he he always just like stands
above it he'll look down and the girls
will come and take it and they'll just
stand back up
he is he watches guard all day he's less
concerned with having food for himself
he just wants to make sure his girls are
all right he's got a lot of girls
there's no chickens saying where have
all the good men gone
he's a good dude and see that's the
thing about chickens
roosters will sacrifice themselves did
you know this did not know that yeah
that's right well I I am offended by
people saying you know using the word
chicken to imply cowardice because a
rooster will charge to its death if it
means buying time of for the hens to
escape to safety wow that's braver than
most humans now somebody gets attacked
on a subway and they just don't
intervene exactly because the rooster
won't get the chicken won't get sued
well they don't want to get involved
this is why I want to donate to Daniel
Penny because he exhibited the the the
spirit of the noble rooster by defending
the people you should tell her somebody
should be told I mean the roost like I I
when I was reading about chickens I was
like wow no for real and then we had a
hawk attack an eagle or I think a hawk I
think we have Eagles out here a hawk
swooped in trying to get our chickens
and then Roberto his dad
a yelled runs to the door because we had
a caged up thing and there's a door they
can come to the Garden it swoops in the
garden he runs out and stands guard in
front of it waiting for all the girls to
go in and then goes in last all right
dude these guys like these are standing
up dudes man thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there